اهتمام كبير وتفاعل واسع بنشوفه في
الاخبار وعلى المنصات مع قرب موعد زفاف
ولي عهد الاردن الامير الحسين بن عبد الله
الثاني من السعوديه رجوى السيف وهاشتاق
نفرح بالحسين مالي المنصات داخل الاردن
وخارجها الزفاف الملكي اللي راح يتم يوم
الخميس اول من يونيو راح يكون في مراسم
ملكيه بدايه من عقد القران في قصر الزهران
اللي هو من اقدم قصور عمان وصار في قبل 30
سنه زفاف الملك عبد الله والملكه رانيا
وايامها كان الملك عبد الله امير بعد عقد
القران في قصر زهران في حفله ومادبه عشاء
في قصر الحسينيه وكان تم الاعلان عن حفل
يوم الاثنين في استاد عمان الدولي ومجاني
للاردنيين للاحتفال بزفاف الامير والحفل
بمشاركه راغب علامه وتامر حسني واحمد سعد
وديانا كرزون وزين عوض وخلال الساعات
الماضيه اللي شاغل الناس هو
حنه رجل لاقيمت في مضارب بني هاشم وكانت
الملكه رانيا نشرت لقطات من التحضير للحنه
والاكسسوارات والزينه فيها واللي واضح انه
اغلبها مشغوله يدويا وكلها بطابع تراثي
العروس رجوله لفتت الانظار في ليله الحنه
بالفستان ابيض مطرز بخيوط الذهب والحرير
من تصميم المصممه السعوديه هنيده الصيرفي
واللي حرصت في تفاصيله على المزج بين
الثقافه السعوديه والاردنيه وقالت انها
صممته ليحكي قصه الحب بين الامير والانسه
الرجوى وتكلمت المصممه عن كل المعاني
والرسائل الموجوده في الفستان والاكثار
يمكن للوهله الاولى ما بيشوفوها لكن لفتت
كمان الى بيت الشعر الظاهر في الفستان وهو
لابو قاسم الشابي اراك فتحلو لدى الحياه
اما فتحلو لدي الحياه اما الملكه رانيا
فطلت بفستان بالازرق من تصميم المصمم
اللبناني سعيد كبيسي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رجوه هي احلى رجاء مني لرب العالمين لحسين
[موسيقى]
يلا يا كريم
يلا
[موسيقى]
وانت غريب الصبايا وين وين
حسين هو فرحه الاولى ابن البكر
شاب هاشمي واعي وعارف انه هو منكم والكم
وزي اي ام انا من زمان بحلم اني اشوفه
عريس حسين ابنكم انتم اهله وهذا عرسكم
واخيرا صار عندي كنه
بس مش اي كنه ما شاء الله عليها رجوى يعني
جد غلاوتها من غلاوه ايمان وسلمى
عزه انا بعرف انا كنت بمحلك قبل شهرين
وبعرف انت كيف شعري بس بدي اطمنك انه رجوى
بعيوننا وبعيون حسين وهي بين اهلها وناسها
فاطمئني عليها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومن يومين نشرت الملكه رانيا على حساباتها
اغنيه لولي العهد من غناء فرقه جماعه خير
الاردنيه الاغنيه للان جامعه 4 مليون
مشاهده وحقيقه مؤثره جدا سواء بكلامها او
باللقطات اللي في الفيديو خصوصا ظهور
الملك الراحل حسين فبتركم مع مقطع من
الاغنيه واعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في
امان الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
شعور جميل وصعب
من اجمل اللحظات كانت لما الولد الله
يرحمه حضن ابني حسين
[موسيقى]
يا ابوي مثل الحلم هالوقت غير غير عيوني
لاغلى ضلاله يا عين دمع الظلم حد
ايامنا تكرج كرج يا ابويا انا يغلى ظنوا
مثل الثلج
[موسيقى]
يا حزران اليوم شاهد عيان
ايش هذا على عرسان اكون
نيالك احزرك ما انت شاهد زمان يوم اللي
كان طفل بحبي
ب لا تبك انا دبكه معاك وارقص خيلي فراخ
وادعي رب الكون
لا لا يا ابوي
الحلم هالوك مرق ما تغني
[موسيقى]